the next talk is going to be this is not
the title slide but I think it's going
to be on sculpting quantum speedups by
Scott Aaronson and shall have been David
and she loves going to be giving the top
okay thanks so yeah I know this is the
the last talked before the free
afternoon so thanks for going yeah I
know life is short and given recent
political events it might be very short
so you know just what we're talking then
we get to enjoy Seattle's attractions
which presumably include walking around
in the rain sitting starbucks coffee I
assume okay so my talk is about
sculpting quantum speed-up switch is
basically a query complexity result in
query complexity we have a boolean
function f and we're given access to you
can Oracle access to a string X and we
want to compute f of X so basically we
get to query the bit of X the cost is
the the number of bits mercury the
number of queries we make and the goal
is to compute f of X so for example if F
is or then the an algorithm can look
something like this here's the input and
these are all boxes that are sealed and
then we can say okay what is in this box
we see a zero what is in that box and so
on if we see a one we know that the or
of all the bits is one so now we can
stop so this took us three queries in
this case right and the query complexity
of F is the worst case number of queries
we would need to make
the wastegate number of queries we need
to make so we will denote it by D of F
for deterministic algorithms are 0 left
40 a randomized and we also have bounded
in a randomized algorithms quantum
algorithms so these are all query
measures that we can define based on
basically what kind of algorithms we are
considering for computing f from the
industry and of course we have cuando
quantum queries faster than randomized
faster than deterministic okay so so
let's just summarize a bit of previous
known results we have I guess one of the
fundamental results is a deals that I'll
result from 98 which says all of the
query measures are defined in the last
slide our colony probably normally
related to each other for total
functions f so this means just for
normal functions f all of these r it up
measures are the same up to polynomial
factors so in last year's Qi key there
is this excellent result by and by
Ernest at all and they basically just
give some surprising polynomial
separations between those same measures
so this tells us they're all polynomial
related but they're not all exactly the
same therefore anomia separations and we
also had a result in last q IP which is
basically even more quibbling over
polynomial factors right and so you know
at this point you'd probably want to say
well you know enough polynomial factors
real complexity theories don't care
about pho nomenal factors where are the
exponential speed ups right so can we
get exponential quantum speed ups for
example in query complexity well we know
you can't for total functions but we
also sort of know that you can so what
is the catch exponential corn feeders
are possible if there's a promise on the
input so if we know that the input
string we are guaranteed in advance that
it will have some f
structure then you can get exponential
speedups using a quantum query algorithm
versus a classical query algorithm so
for example the promise might be the
input string has some periodicity okay
so this is the basic story of queer
complexity here I so for this talk we
want to ask you know when are these
exponential quantum speedups possible
right so we know they're sometimes
possible if you have the right promise
in the input okay but but for what types
of functions so again for total
functions we're not going to get
anything if there's a promise maybe okay
but for what kinds of functions what
kind of promises can we say anything
else about when we get exponential
quantum speed ups in particular we're
going to ask the following question
given a total function f is there a
promise that we can put on f such that
there you'll get exponential quantum
speedups once we add in this promise
okay so this is a property of this its
other possible or not possible to add in
a promise and then get an exponential
speed and we're going to call this is
what we're going to call the sculpting
problem ok so again the sculpting
question is given a total function f is
there a promise such that their
exponential quantum sweet ups after we
add in the problem in other words let's
more colloquially we're going to say you
know we know there's probably no
exponential quantum speed-up for 3sat
because it's NP complete but maybe on
some special set of instances of three
set right maybe there we want to say
basically we want a press headline that
looks like this you know there's an
exponential cuantos treated for three
stat with a little star it says well if
you restrict your sufficiently
artificial set of 3sat inputs ok so our
result basically characterizes at least
in queer complexity when
this is possible for what functions you
can restrict them to promise to get
exponential fields okay so let's just go
with a quick example here example is the
or function we had at the beginning can
we restrict the or function to a promise
such that on inputs from that promise
there's an exponential quantum speed-up
okay so let's just think about this for
a second so again the inputs are just
these n boxes right and we we want to if
we if we put in a strong enough promise
it will be easy to solve the or function
maybe I promise you the boxes are either
all 0 or all one right if I promise that
then just open one box that's enough
right but that won't you give you a gap
between randomized and quantum
algorithms that will just make them both
small right so can you come up with a
promise that makes the quantum algorithm
fast but the randomized algorithm still
slow okay
what do you guys think
okay so I mean for the or function the
answer is no which is maybe intuitive
this is a result of Aronson from 2004 so
actually the speedup is exactly
quadratic so that's kind of neat no
matter what you promised you put quantum
algorithms will be quadratically faster
than the randomized albums okay so let's
try a different example what about the
parody function so now we want the
parody of the bits in the boxes can we
restrict that to a promise such that now
it's easy for quantum algorithms but
still hard classically
so the answer is actually yes there's a
trick you can do which looks something
like this let's split the input into two
parts now we want the parody of all the
boxes but but we'll cut it up here and
over here we'll add in the promise that
you know this part of the input
satisfies the promise for Simon's
problem which is just a problem where we
know you can do exponentially faster
with quantum algorithms so we're here
we'll just say this part of the input
satisfies that promise and over here
we'll just put in some string that such
that the total parody of this whole
string will be you know the value of
silence problem on this string so this
part will just be whatever it needs to
be to turn the problem truly into
silence problem okay so now our quantum
algorithm can just look here it doesn't
even need to look at the rest and Saul
Simon's problem in in like poly log in
but a classical randomized algorithm
well it can't look here because then
it's trying to solve Simon's problem
over here well over here there's no
structure it's just a parity so you can
show that that this works that the
classical algorithm will have nothing
that it can do so we'll need you know
it's potentially more than the quantum
algorithm okay so ah now our result is a
characterization so before I tell you
what it is maybe maybe you can try to
guess what's the difference between an
or and a parity right what what will the
characterization be right what what
property puts or on one side and says
this is not sculpt abul and puts
priority on the other side says this is
scott
okay all right so let me just let me go
on a bit of a tangent before I tell you
the answer and this is going to be
relevant eventually we'll talk about H
indices do you guys know what in each
index is it's it's used to measure
research output it's like the maximum
number K such that you have at least K
publications with at least K citations
each this is your H index and actually
we're going to consider a variant that I
think is better and everybody should
switch to it it goes uh you know the
maximum number K such as we have at
least 2 to the K publications with at
least k citations each okay so this is
what we're going to call the h-index in
this talk this uh this 2 to the K
variant so if you go to your Google
Scholar page it probably looks something
like this you have your list of
publications and over there in the
corner you see the h-index right and
order siz in H index is can you think it
says 108 you know and there's also an
800 since 2011 I assume they mean
citations since 2011 rather than
publications that would be truly
impressive okay so all right so here's
what we're going to do we're going to
look at this citation at the google
scholar page for the or function it's
going to look something like this this
is actually you got the wrong picture
here this is an odd function okay so ah
alright so we're going to look at this
is the google scholar page the
publications are going to be the inputs
so inputs we're going to call them
publications there's always two to the
end of them right because there are 2 to
the N strings bullying strings are on
end of sizable Langton okay and the
citations are going to be something
called the certificate complexity of the
input so here we have the inputs here we
have the value of it but select this is
the 0 0 or of this string is 0 or this
ring is one
right so there's only 10 value
everything else is one and in the third
problem here we're going to have the
certificate complexity of the input what
is the certificate complexity it's the
number of bits I would have to show you
to convince you that this input truly
has this value that this value is
correct right so for this input you know
I have I can I have to show you all of
the bits to prove to you that it's a
zero input but for every other input I
can just show you the one wherever it is
and that will convince you that or of
this set of strings is one right so the
certificate so that we're going to call
those the citation so here or has one
input with very good citation with any
citations right the end certificate
complexity every other input has one so
the h-index for or is one okay ah okay
but what about for parody so this is the
google scholar page to authority again
the same number of publications to the
end it's always to the end but now the
certificate complexity is n for every
input so every input i need to show you
all the bits before you're convinced of
its parity okay so this is just n
everywhere and the hn x will be n right
there's two to the N publications with n
citations each okay so we're going to
claim that the h-index as defined like
this actually characterizes sculpt
ability so basically this is the agent
of the certificate complexity of the
function and we're going to say that's
Coptic what we're going to prove that
sculpting is possible if and only if the
h-index of the certificate complexity of
the function is large so for or it was
one so sculpting is not possible for
parodies and so sculpting is possible
formerly the statement the statement
looks like this basically so we can try
to parse this up saying for every
function f which ever function you give
me there will be a promise that you can
restrict you such that the randomized
algorithm takes at least
the h-index of F to the power 1 / 6 /
some logs ok so the randomized algorithm
will take time polynomial in the h-index
but the quantum algorithm will take time
logarithmic in the h-index ok so if the
h-index is large this is an exponential
separation ok the second statement is is
sort of the other direction and it's
saying for every function no matter what
promise you try to restrict to the
randomized and quantum poor complexities
of f restrictions the promise will be
polynomially related but there'll be a
a factor of the h-index there so if
the h-index is small this is a true
polynomial relationship but if the
h-index is like large is like n then
this gives you nothing ok so together
these results say the h-index is really
what you care about if its large you can
sculpt if it's small you cannot
ok so we eat this is the the main result
we also have few other results you can
ask sculpting not for randomized versus
quantum you can just take any of these
other query complexity measures and ask
the same question there so here you can
ask d versus r0 the deterministic vs 0
error randomized actually it's the same
characterization so the h-index comes up
again and it's just the same
characterization ok what about our 0 vs
are so 0 error versus bounded air here
it turns out it's always possible to
sculpt and you can the rough intuition
here is just again the or function think
of the or function you know think about
trying to restrict it to a promise such
that you know under this promise you can
solve it faster with a zero error
randomized versus deterministic if you
think about this you'll realize this is
not possible these are always going to
be the same the zero errand for fourth
day or function but on the other hand
for bounded error you do get an
advantage for computing or if you
restrict to the right promise right why
is that because you guys see it I can
restrict to the promise that says the
Hamming weight of my string is either 0
or n over 2 right and now if I want to
make sure I didn't make any errors I
still sort of you know I suppose I query
and I keep seeing zeroes right so I can
be pretty sure it's the 0 input and not
the half ones input if I query randomly
and keep seeing zeros but if I want to
be completely sure i'm going to make
like n queries right if I am ok with
bounded error then I can just solve it
in constant queries constant queries
I'll see no one's I'll know that the
input is probably the 0 ok
all right so I guess there's a bit of a
some philosophical questions here why
the h-index came up why why certificates
let's let's answer this one first why
certificates how is that related to the
sculpting question the answer is it sort
of is not because actually the the
h-index of certificate complexity is
polynomial in related to the h-index of
block sensitivity and the h-index of a
bunch of other measures you could have
put there so really when we say
characterized by certificate by the
agent of certificate complexity well
after polynomial factors which we lose
anyway it's the same as the h-index of
block sensitivity or of other measures
so really this H index is after
polynomial factors something fundamental
but the certificates are not that
fundamental here okay right um so
intuitively what is the h-index doing
here it's saying is the number of hard
inputs the inputs say that are hard to
certify is that number smaller large
right if the entry injections are just
saying almost every input or many inputs
are hard not just one input is hard if
the agent X is small like four or it's
saying there's really only one spot
where the function is hard really around
the zero input for or the function is
hard elsewhere it's not hard so if the
function is hard everywhere you have
more room to sculpt you know you're
starting with a larger sculpting block
if the function is only hard in one spot
I have less room to sculpt so so in fact
you cannot
so this is the intuitive argument here
okay so let's quickly go through just
one slide on a proof sketch for the
impossibility direction so how do you
show that you know for example or cannot
be sculpted right we want to show that
randomized algorithm and quantum
algorithms are polynomial related as
long as you add in this H index term
right so basically we're saying if
there's few large certificates are and
QR quadratically related this is what we
want to show so the argument looks
roughly like this it says okay step one
we're going to use this standard
argument of that deterministic
algorithms are at most the square
certificate complexity if you don't know
it that's okay but this is a standard
argument in quai complexity and we'll
just apply it here and it will sort of
try to kill the small certificates
because we know d is large to begin with
we'll try to apply this argument to like
to remove small certificates if we do
this we'll have few one inputs left and
the step 2 will be show the quadratic
relationship when your when your
function has a few one inputs when your
function on your promise has few one
inputs left then you will try to we will
try to show will just show that there's
a put our relationship whenever that
happens okay and this is what we do and
we get along the way this nice side
result it's basically says actually a
quantum Corey complexity for any
function even a partial function is
quadratic Lee related in at least root
of the deterministic we're complexity
but divided by the log of the domain
size of your function right so you can
view this as a tool for lower bound in
quantum query complexity if you want
right this tool says okay I suppose I
want to lower bound quantum great
complexity of the or function I want to
show it's like rude
okay so first I'll just restrict you the
promise where the the input is either
the all 0 string or it has or atomic
weight 1 so now I've restricted to a set
of size n plus 1 only n plus 1 strings
left and I'll show that even on this set
the quantum queer complexity is large
okay so how will I show this well the
deterministic queer complexity is
clearly large that's not hard to show
because you'll just deterministically
query you'll keep seeing zero so the
German sequeira complexity is N and then
you plug into this result and you get
rude n divided by log n plus 1 is up to
constant factors a lower bound on the
quantum queer complexity ok that's it so
you get the Grove Road around with a log
factor loss but you didn't have to do
any work you just you just plug this in
so you know on the scale of quantum
query lower bound techniques this is a
pretty weak technique but it's but it's
a very easy to use the cake so it's a
trade-off between like easy to use and
the strength of the ticking ok ah this
on the slide ok the the proof idea for
proving this is basically if you know
what the this randomized certificate
versus quantum certificate result of
Aronson from 2004 this is basically
generalizing that I would say the key
part of the proof technique ok so I'll
briefly sketch the sculpting existence
result that's the other direction why
priority is possible to sculpt I mean we
saw it for parody but why is it always
possible if H index is large so here you
know we we want to find a promise that
has a certain property right that makes
leaves the random the classical were
complexity large but makes the quantum
query come back it is small basically
saying if there are many hard inputs we
can find the problems on which is an
exposure
eration so the step one will be we
actually don't want to use certificates
we want to use the block sensitivity
thing I was talking about before step
two is something called sours lemma I'll
briefly talk about Sarah's lemma and ass
step 3 will be using a communication
complexity result so that's just very
quickly look at that Sarah's lemma is
this a kind of cool technique about sets
of booming string is a cool result about
sets of bullying strings that is very
good to know it's saying if you have a
set of bullying strings like here we
have these five strings then you can if
it's a large if it's a large set you can
always find a set of positions like
these two positions bits basically of
these strings we're on those bits you
have every possible action so on those
bits you have every possible string or
in those which you have 0 0 here 110 110
ok so on those bits you have every
possible action ok and you have a
guarantee on the size of the set the
size of the set would be log s divided
by log in at least ok so it's always if
s is like to the n or s is is to to the
poly on or something you will always
have a large set of positions where you
have every string if you just restricted
those positions okay so this is
basically saying we know that we're the
function that has a large h-index so
basically there are many hard inputs
right there many hard inputs wii u
storage them and we can say the hard
inputs basically look like this over in
these bits you have every possible
action over in these bits well we don't
know what happens right it can be
anything it's not every possible action
right let's call it some function of the
X here so here you have every possible
option here you have some function of X
that's what that all the hard inputs we
can assume have this structure and by
sarahs lemma this expert won't be too
small
okay so um okay right so now we want to
define a promise we want to restrict
this set of heart strings to a promise
such that quantum algorithms can solve
it fast and randomized cannot randomized
all solution on so what we'll do is you
will just put the promise on the expert
will say well here we started with every
possible string right let's just put
silence promise there right and the
problem is okay you don't just get
access to the ex parte you get back says
to the whole string so you could you
could worry you know maybe this says
Simon's problem but here this s of X
tells you the solution to Simon's
problem just in the third bit so the
determinate you know even a
deterministic algorithm can solve
Simon's problem by looking at the third
because maybe this string just
tells you the solution and and you know
in fact maybe maybe this SFX parts
contains the answer to every possible
function that can be solved in
logarithmic time with the quantum
algorithm right so maybe not just for
Simon's but for every function where you
have a quantum sweta the f's part will
will will tell you the answer can that
happen and this is where our reduction
to communication come in comes in
basically we take a communication task
where you have a quantum speed-up so
communication task has an X and the y
right um so this the X will be
identified with this S will give that to
one of the players in the communication
game 2 Bob and then we'll consider
giving strings why to Alice that satisfy
the the promise of the communication
problem and now we consider Alice
strategies that look like this classical
strategies that look like this Alice
knows why she wants to find out
basically the joint function of x and y
she asks questions either about X or
about s of X she asked questions
basically from this string she basically
queries this string by asking bulb
questions
okay she does this and she tries to
using a classical algorithm solve the
communication task that you know we said
she cannot solve because we know we pick
the communication task to be hard to
solve classically okay so this is this
is the situation she's going to try to
solve the communication task that she's
not supposed to be able to solve by
asking Bob questions from X or s of X
basically by querying this tree we know
that will fail okay what does it mean
that it will fail it will mean that
basically there is some input Y for
which alex cannot do this with few
queries there exists a wise such that
Alice cannot do cannot solve the
communication game with the strategy
quickly okay now we will fix this Y all
right if we fix a why in a communication
problem and we look at possibilities for
X we really get a query from we get a
function of X we get a function of X
right where f of X is you know the
communication game of XY after we fix
them so that is going to be the function
that we will put here for X ok so we
will restrict X to the promise you know
we will place on X here the function
that you get from this communication
problem after we fixed y to make this
problem hard and then we can show that
you know there's no strategy query
strategy that the classical query
strategy that does this quickly ok
so probably hard to follow that let me
just in two minutes talk about sculpting
in the Turing machine model so in the
Turing machine models there is no longer
query complexity in the Turing machine
model we can ask sort of a similar
question we can say a language is
comfortable if you can restrict it to a
promise such that now it's in promise v
QP but not in promise BPD can solve like
quantum algorithms but not by classical
algorithms ok so to be sculpted all at
all we must start with the language
that's hard which we start with the
language outside of BPD it turns out
that if a language is something called
paddle you can add in relevant junked to
any input like three seth has this
property it turns out that for those
languages we can show sculpt ability
assuming a complexity theory conjecture
that promised v QP is harder than
average for p / bali ok and we have
another result that says actually every
language can be sculpted in the turing
machine model if you assume a stronger
conjecture which it which says that
there is a vp t by mu in language for b
QP ok doesn't matter exactly what that
is but if you assume sufficiently strong
conjectures you get sufficiently strong
result again you know equally strong
result ok so just to conclude we gave a
full characterization of sculpting in
the in the query model we wanted to say
something like this right we wanted to
say quantum computers gave an exponent
given exponential speed-up for some 3sat
instances this is now a complexity
theory approved or since I'm going to
say it is Scott's not here don't don't
tell him I said this ok actually no this
is fine it's just the the word some here
is doing a lot of work right this sum is
going to be particularly artificial 3sat
instances not any ones that come up
naturally ok and then we showed most
boolean functions are culpable so one
thing we can conclude for one conclusion
I draw from this work is that
team speed ups are fundamentally not
about the function so much as they are
about the promise the promise tells you
a lot of information about whether
you're going to have the quantum
speed-up the function tells you you know
even party can be restricted to a
promise so you know the function doesn't
tell you that much about whether you're
going to get a quantum speed-up
certainly not as much as the promise and
you know for future work I i think you
know I sort of want to push this
question as a community we should
address which promises give rise to
quantum speedos for which promises can
you find a function where you have
exponential wonder street can we
characterize those it seems like a much
harder task okay thanks all right we
have time for questions
over them
if given the Oracle f can we compute as
you index in the polynomial time right
so the h-index okay so okay so the
h-index is a reasonably simple measure
so if you give me the truth table of the
function as input so that's an
exponentially login long input in n
right because this truth table of the
function yeah then I think so I wonder
the way stated that maybe the answer is
no but just because you can't sort of
tell anything about the function in
polynomial time if you want to be
polynomial in n so you've got to be a
bit careful here but basically the
h-index is simple enough that you know
for any function you give me I can
quickly tell you what the index is we
can compute it for parity we can compute
it for majority for endor trees for
whatever you want so I think at least
from what we can prove about it point of
view it's a simple enough
characterization
more questions
when constructing an Oracle you often
have a situation with you some
complicated arbitrary function and then
you reduce it to a true false by some
method like saying is the output of my
complicated function inside of the
following set or does the output of the
complicated function have an answer less
than or equal to some constant generally
speaking if you could come up with some
promise that used the characteristics of
the pre-existing complicated function as
it moves toward the Oracle function that
would be very helpful do you have any
ideas about what techniques exactly
would allow us to sculpt these kind of
functions to produce the exponential
speed-up ah ok so the sculpting results
here which basically says that most
functions are sculpted lure in the
Turing machine model maybe even all
functions are sculpted or languages so
those are very strong results and
they're really cheating right because
they're really restricting to a
particularly artificial set that turns
your function into a completely
different function you're finding inside
your problem well they're not finding
Simon's exactly you're finding this
instance of the communication task but
you can think of it as finding Simon's
somewhere hidden in your function so you
know from that perspective I think this
result doesn't have that much
application of the sort that you're
hoping for like of the sort that you
know maybe you can sculpt in some
natural way I think sculpting in a
natural way you know will be dependent
on the exact functions you're looking
for so that you know there's some work
by there's some work on and/or trees by
I think Stacey Jeffrey and Shelby Kimmel
and maybe someone else where they
basically essentially show you know
maybe a more natural sculpting for how
to sculpt specifically one function that
and/or tree so for one specific function
you know they work hard and they show a
sort of more natural sculpting
effectively right so using this you can
say okay well all functions are sculpted
but in a very ugly way so if you want a
natural sculpting I think it will be
much too much more difficult
any more questions no we're here
so I think you to get this result you
use the next natural gap between
classical and quantum in communication
complexity right I was wondering if you
can use this gap to prove another gap in
somewhere else I sorry like you use the
exponential gap in communication
complexity to get an exponential gap in
very complexity was wondering if you can
do something similar using the
exponential gap in American flag city
yeah I'm not sure I mean yeah I'm like I
guess exponential since communication
complexity sort of so much hard to prove
things about there's a financial
expectation that you know once you
manage to prove it it will be a very
useful result and here we indeed see you
know it has all these applications the
query complexity results I would say are
somewhat easier to prove so you may be
expect to have somewhat less
applications but so for example this
particular query result I don't know
what its other applications are I could
actually so one quick point is that
cheat sheets talked about that in the
last qfp have this flavor a bit where
you take a partial function separation
and you turn it into a total function
separation in queer complexity so that's
a query complexity to query complexity
reduction of speed ups maybe that's what
you're looking for
any more questions all right if not
let's thank the speaker
[Applause]